i've always been a little bitter
within myself not anybody else like gosh
i should have been on that show
because i'll tell you why she opened for
me
at the sacramento uh punch line
and she was getting ready to montreal
the next week great club and
she she had been working and i i'd been
where she'd been she was she gave me
new faces i think yeah so i did it the
year before and i
bombed at new faces and she was like um
she was thursday night she's pissed she
goes what the [ __ ] she's at the bar and
she's
like pounding these drinks right and i
go what's wrong and she goes
i'm doing montreal next week and this
[ __ ] set's been working
and it's not working right now but my
audience is not montreal's audience
so i told the club i go this is going to
sound racist
i go blacks and mexicans in the back
put all the older white people in the
front i go
because i and i told her i said focus on
the front yeah
we're going to put all the blacks and
the latinos in the back of the room
it's not a big room as it is yeah you'll
focus on the first two rows man
and her set got the audience was better
as the week went on right
and then i just remember she was she
dropped me off at the residence inn
she had a volkswagen and she dropped me
off and i wished her good luck in
montreal and i said you're gonna be good
i said you're you're attractive
i said you got like this um you got an
attitude about you i said
they're gonna eat you up montreal you'll
be fine and then she went
as i i'm acting like her agent you'll be
fine yeah yeah yeah you'll be good
and then she went uh i just remember
going are you where are you staying she
goes i'm driving back guys you're
driving to ellie now
it's like midnight yeah i'm just gonna
drive back i said
all right then she took off and then she
got the deal and got the show and i
always
remember going oh [ __ ] i put the blocks
in here
i look out for you i root it for you and
i can't get on
one [ __ ] episode
i gave you the encouragement to kill
montreal oh my god i gave you your push
out of the nest baby
she has to remember i guarantee she does
but i've been to the sacramento punch
line because the year before
i had did new faces and [ __ ] bombs
i never did you think the the set didn't
go the last time i didn't trust my
gut because i was with caa at that time
and at that time people were leaving
there with big holding deals
right yeah and they were grooming all
these networks
to come see me and they go don't worry
about the audience reaction you're just
trying to get your point of view across
because we're basing a show off this set
this five minute set dude by the way i
remember that period of comedy
when your manager and agent were just
like what's your pov give me f you give
me your point of view in five minutes
tell me tell them who you are so they
can make a show about you there was a
about a two-year period where yeah
that's where they get developmental data
and they were just grooming you they
were like just get five minutes together
don't worry about
hours or 20 minutes they just wanted you
to get five minutes together i remember
that
when i and i went up and i heard don
barrera hosted
they didn't really laugh at dom and i'm
first
i'm the first guy it's new faces i'm the
first guy
it's 6 p.m and it was daylight i
remember going
i looked in the audience it was old
white like i literally saw a lady with
blue hair it was like oh
and they didn't like dumb here's here's
the story i got later so i went up there
i didn't get
nothing in five minutes and i got off
stage and right before i walked on stage
i looked at my age and i go
i'm gonna switch my setup i go there
they're not gonna get the five minutes
i'm talking about it goes no no
stick to the five minutes got the
networks here don't worry about the
laughs yikes but you know we feed off
energy yeah
flat i got off stage i went out the back
door of the club
my hotel is about two miles away i
started walking back cussing the whole
way my wife
wasn't even that wasn't my girlfriend at
the time she's like a hundred yards
behind me cause she knows my man go [ __ ]
because in my brain you knew i was like
i didn't go to any parties the next two
days because i had two days before i
went up again
i thought everybody's like that's the
guy bomb that's got a bomb i didn't do
anything they would invite me hey
everybody's getting together like nope
nope nope i watched more cfl football
in two days i never watched my life i
knew all the montreal
[ __ ] alouettes or whatever it was
that's right so
two days later i show up for the second
new faces showcase and now
i got a new five minutes i'm like okay
i'm ready tonight find out everybody
bombed
all eight comics that audience [ __ ]
sucks oh really
everybody ate it but it didn't make me
feel any better which set did you do
the second one the one you had done
initially or the new one
no the second said it was just about
montreal five minutes about
the city and i walked around for two
days and got to know [ __ ] and it crushed
right it was good i wouldn't say crushed
it was good
yeah but i end up getting a holding deal
because guy torey missed his flight
and the urban show i had to they asked
me to stay an extra night and fill in i
go
yeah i can do that yeah and that's the
night i killed and i got a holding deal
with quincy jones
because quincy saw all four of my sets
oh wow
he goes yo he goes i went i saw your
sets he goes
you didn't do well the first night you
adjusted did better the second night he
goes and then when you did the urban
shows you did two
first show you did clean the second show
you went dirty because that's what they
told us
and i was like he goes so i saw you
adjust you did four different sets
four different but it's only five
minutes i did 20 minutes but still dude
that's
that's to do four different sets and to
have the balls to do four different sets
especially at that time when all of our
people were telling you
if you want to make it you got to make
it in montreal like there was so much
pressure to do that
and the fact that you had the balls to
ditch that first set that you had been
working on the whole time and just do
three is is huge
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic
son